[Music]
this morning the mining project that is
either critical to america's clean
energy future or a pending mess in the
american west depending on who you speak
with the mining site in question idaho
has a long and storied history
now it's back in the news as a new
company seeks to reopen the mine that
hasn't been used in more than two
decades they believe they can remove
billions of dollars of gold buried in
the ground while fixing damage done in
the past and increasing national
security
not everyone is buying
our trip to the mining site in central
idaho took us through some of the
wildest land in the country over
mountains and past landslides
eventually arriving in remote yellow
pine and stib night for 150 years miners
have come here seeking to dig their
fortune the latest arrival perpetua
resources
laurel sayer is the ceo we still need
gold in society today it's not just used
for jewelry we use it in electronics
it's a very valuable mineral that we use
the stem night mine was abandoned in the
1990s
but a toxic legacy was left behind
changes to the river that flows through
the mine site meant fish spawning
upstream were left without clear passage
to the pacific ocean
perpetua says they can clean up the mess
left behind by for one reconnecting the
river the first thing we do is pick up
hundreds of thousands of yards of tails
and move those so that those are no
longer contaminating the site plus they
say there's another big reason to dig
antimony a chemical element that's a
byproduct of the gold extraction process
and something that's crucial for the
production of green technology including
batteries for electric vehicles
in the 1940s antimony mined here and
used in the production of ammunition
helped the u.s win world war ii
today the vast majority is produced in
china and russia none in the u.s which
some say is a national security risk
if we sit and do nothing
we will never solve this problem we want
to do something now because we're
already behind so if there is an
opportunity
to help advance the clean energy agenda
for the u.s we should be doing it
not everyone agrees
the 13.2 million acres that make up the
section of idaho where the mine is
located was the original home of a
native american tribe known as the nez
purse or namipu just probably 40 miles
outside of spokane you're in our
traditional territory nakia williamson
feels after losing their land of the
gold rush of the 1800s the namipu have
given enough we had to sustain so much
loss already with many other impacts
that have happened to the land the other
transformation of this landscape and one
more impact could
be too much for for us to sustain it's
an enormous mine and it's going to
increase almost uh over two times the
size as it is now
right down there emmett taylor is
another tribal leader who we met at the
south fork of the salmon river which
once contained the most thriving
population of chinook salmon in the
world remember my niece catching her
first salmon here lyanna oh yeah yeah
today because of pollutants like those
released from mining operations in the
past
overfishing and dams that block fish
migration it's estimated only one
percent of the salmon that used to run
this section of the river remain our
whole goal is to try to
restore the fishery bring the fishery
back
to get the
salmon back to a sustainable level
from it for an ecological standpoint and
also from a harvest standpoint
it's a complex issue they mean there's a
lot of
a lot of stakeholders the namipu are not
the only ones pushing back on the
perpetua plan
nick nilsson is the executive director
of idaho rivers united if this project
happens
a generation from now
what do you think this portion of the
country looks like
i see a huge scar at the
headwaters of the south fork of the
salmon
you know i see
what could be a sterile river with the
mining company and the area that they'll
be working in and all the different
conditions that are there it's not a
question of
if a spill is ever going to occur or if
an accident's ever going to occur it's
um it's a matter of when
perpetua does have many supporters
including politicians and locals lynn
immel has lived in the tiny town of
yellow pine near the mine since 1968.
how old is this crucible
this is probably from the late 1800s
the prospect of new jobs and a
reconnected river is intriguing for
those like her who remain i'm totally in
favor of the mine
and the mess that is left
has to be cleaned up there are some who
feel there's going to be a whole new
mess
left behind after i think the
regulations will totally control it you
think
government's not going to clean that up
but you think private
industry can
i think they will how long would the
mining last for 15 years we have always
been transparent about who we are and
what we're doing up here that we're a
modern mining project what is a modern
mining project mean
we put in for example the restoration
part of our project
we're actually restoring habitat for the
fish and the critters that they can
thrive up here once we're done and it's
even before we're done if their plan
and the science were as good as their pr
were then i'd have a lot less concerns
about it but
it really isn't at some point we have to
shift away from fossil fuels move away
from them
extracting metals like this allows that
to happen why is that a bad idea this
isn't an anti-extraction or an
anti-mining campaign it's
you know mining needs to be done we all
recognize that but it needs to be done
responsibly and there are certain
locations that it's never going to be
responsible
last year the environmental protection
agency centered had significant concerns
about harm to fish and that water
treatment at the site would be needed
forever
perpetual revised that plant and said
they'll shrink the mine's footprint and
lessen the impact on the environments
the review process of that new plan has
just been extended for another two years
idaho rivers united and the namipu
consider that a victory
for now we are accountable to this land
and we are the voice for this land and
so it's our responsibility to continue
to advocate for those that no longer
have the voice and has been imparted to
us and that's the responsibility that we
carry as namibu do you believe there's a
compromise here
i really struggle to find a compromise
here from what they want to do
when i asked the tribe if they thought
there was any room for compromise
they said no
can you do this project without them i
would hope that they wouldn't say no
forever and i would hope that they would
come to the table and we could
fix this
the process the permitting process does
allow us to move forward
but our door is always open
we want to find a compromise we want to
work with them
such beautiful land and such a tough
debate no matter what happens you're
talking long term here if it gets
approved you're talking years of
construction then 15 to 20 years of
mining um and i think a lot of people
are just wondering whatever happens here
what this area is going to look like a
generation from now and i love that the
tribe speaks for the land you want them
on your side you don't want to do
without them yeah and that this is
playing out though in a public way i
think that's so important that this
discussion is actually taking place
whereas this is something that didn't
always happen as we well know in our
history in the past transparency yeah
thanks jeff good story